- Welcome back to our
teacher appreciation hour
and an audience, full of
teachers and students.
We are also with the cast
of Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness.
Benedict Cumberbatch, Elizabeth Olson,
Benedict Wong and Xochitl Gomez!
(audience cheering)
In the new movie,
all of these very talented
actors play characters, endowed
with magical powers.
I am the only one here without any magic
and I'm very sad about it.
I feel like I have magic deep inside.
- You're a kick-ass musician
of the highest order.
- See, thank you!
- That is a magic power.
(everyone applauding)
- Thank you, a super power.
Anyway, to celebrate Doctor Strange
and all things magical, it is time
for a game called, That'll Do The Trick.
(upbeat music)
♪ That'll do the trick ♪
So, teams are The Benedicts
versus The Winners.
- [Benedict] Oh, it's like that?
- Yeah, it's on, oh yeah, it's on.
- Oh, oh, oh, okay.
- [Kelly] I'm very competitive.
- Glad my sleeves are already
rolled up, yeah, all right.
- C and W better be ready.
And to host, let's call upon the man
with the magical voice,
Lord are you there?
- [Host] I am here, how you doing Kelly?
- I'm so good.
- [Host] Hey Elizabeth, hey Benedict W,
hey Xochitl, hey Briar
Patch, how you all doing?
(Kelly laughing)
- Good thanks, God.
- [Host] Very good to see you.
Here we go Briar Patch, here's
how today's game works, okay?
I'm gonna ask a question
that has to do with magic.
Now, it might be from a story,
might be a real life magician,
it might be a magic trick.
Now, if you know the answer, buzz in.
Now, you may buzz in before
I finish the question
but then, you will not hear
the rest of the question.
- Fine.
- [Host] And, if you are
wrong, steals are allowed.
- Ooh.
- Steals.
- [Host] That's right.
Now, if The Benedicts win,
their photo will go up
on the not so magical,
Blake Shelton Wall of Champions
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
- [Kelly] Stupid wall.
- [Host] That's my
favorite wall in the world.
- Stupid wall!
Stupid wall!
(contestants laughing)
- [Host] Here we go.
The first question is, who was the name
of the magician who served
in King Arthur's?
(buzzer ringing)
- Merlin.
- [Host] It was Merlin.
- How did you know it already?
- [Host] That's right.
(audience applauding)
- The full question, wasn't even there!
- It's slightly terrifying, really.
- [Xochitl] This is so sad.
- You know you hit the buzzer you're like-
- I knew that was gonna be Merlin
but he didn't even to
the full, whatever Wong.
- I pressed the buzzer
and then I made him say
it, isn't that amazing?
That'll do the trick.
- That's how we do it.
- That'll do the trick.
- WC, no, no, CW, WC sounds wrong.
- [Kelly] We are not doing well!
- [Host] That's what I'm talking about.
- I'm not good at trivia,
y'all, I'm so sorry.
- [Host] All right, CW,
come on now, ladies.
Here we go, let's get it together.
Here's your next question.
Next question is, in what animated movie
was the magical antagonist named Jafar?
- Oh, Aladdin!
(buzzer dinging)
- [Host] It was Aladdin!
(everyone applauding)
There you go.
- You go ahead with that
Disney stuff, I got that.
- [Host] Uh-huh, well, that's
the last one we gonna do then.
Okay, here you go.
Here's the next question,
get ready for it.
This is goin' be a tough one.
- Okay.
- In the Marvel cinematic universe,
what mischievous character shares a name
with a magical shapeshifting...
- [Duo] Loki.
- [Host] It is Loki!
(bell dinging)
- [Kelly] I love it when we're right!
(audience cheering)
- [Host] Okay, here's the next one, okay?
Now, in what Shakespeare
play, do the Weird Sisters
also known...
(buzzer ringing)
- Macbeth.
- The Scottish Play.
- [Host] It is,
(bell dinging)
(audience cheering)
the Scottish Play, thank you for saying-
- [Kelly] Of course,
he's English, we're good.
- [Elizabeth] Whatever.
- Whatever.
- Whatever I don't care.
- Bitter.
(horn blaring)
- Is this a double?
- This is br-br-br.
- [Host] This is, for double the points,
it is our final question.
- Never played this before,
but I knew it was a double.
- [Host] Now, this is your big chance.
This is your big chance,
Benedicts, so get ready.
- Come one Shakespeare.
(Elizabeth chuckling)
- [Host] And, I appreciate
you saying The Scottish Play
by the way, otherwise it
would've cursed all of our asses.
Okay, here we go now.
(Kelly laughing)
Next question, the final question.
What is the name of the
cape worn by Doctor Strange?
(buzzer dinging)
- Oh!
- Name of the cape.
- Oh dang it!
- I know this!
- Dang it!
- It's a cloak.
- No, it's a cloak but it's-
- It's okay, Cloak of Levitation.
- Oh!
- Cloak of Levitation!
(buzzer dinging)
- Yes!
- What just happened?
We gotta do another round.
(everyone laughing)
(buzzer dinging)
- [Host] It is the Cloak of Levitation.
God says that's correct.
(audience cheering)
(horn blaring)
- Oh, that's gotta
hurt, that's gotta hurt.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my gosh, this was actually
my favorite part of this,
"What happened, well, we've
gotta do another round."
(everyone laughing)
She sensed our loss.
- I know.
- No, no!
- Okay, whatever.
How did I get that wrong?
- I don't know if I've ever-
- I've never heard that
name before in my life.
- I don't know if I've
ever really paid attention
to the, I'm very mad at myself right now.
- [Benedict] He's your favorite character.
- I know, my mom is
gonna, you have no idea,
she's gonna be like,
"You're a disappointment."
- Do they really call it that?
- When do you call it that?
- The Cloak of Levitation.
- When it gets, on my back.
- [Kelly] No!
- Yeah.
It's called Cloak, as well
as Cloak of Levitation.
- I said Cloak!
- But, it's a cloak,
but I didn't know it was like, whatever!
- Not a cloak, it's the cloak.
- [Xochitl] I could've
gotten a half a point.
- You know what, you know what?
- [Benedict] Yeah.
- Since Team Benedict won,
their picture will be placed
on this dumb wall called,
The Blake Shelton Wall of
Champions who beat Kelly Clarkson.
(audience cheering)
I wish I could use magic
to make it disappear.
- [Benedict] Feels good, it feels good.
(audience applauding)